it wasn't a warm welcome from Extinction
Rebellion protesters for the Home
Secretary
once they've been chucked out suela
bravman said she wanted to welcome
rather fewer legal immigrants we need to
get overall immigration numbers down
and we mustn't forget how to do things
for ourselves
the Home Secretary was speaking in
Westminster on just the other side of
the Thames Lambeth is home to many of
those who make up the biggest source of
legal migration International students
we spoke to two who are planning on
staying to work in the UK after their
studies finish it's quite sad
studying so hard and having such amazing
results at University that it would kind
of it would definitely not be the same
without them I think if it's something
that is discouraging for students to
come you'd feel like it's this of a
welcoming environment especially as an
immigrant after a lull because of the
pandemic Visa grants have surged back
sponsored study visas and visas given to
their dependents are the largest chunk
shown in Brown
the question is how much of a long-term
difference that makes
for example more than 220 000 people
were issued a sponsored study Visa in
2011. a decade later only 13 percent of
them remained in the UK fewer than 30
000.
and in the meantime students bring in a
huge amount of money to the treasury
higher education related exports the
vast majority of which is international
students paying fees in the UK were
worth 19.5 billion pounds in 2021.
that's not much less than exports for
the entire British pharmaceutical sector
last year and it's even more than
Aerospace exports 15.2 billion in 2021
we've been focusing on students because
it's such a large part of the total and
it shows some of the complexity because
usually when we talk about immigration
it's in terms of just a number and
usually for the politicians talking
about it that number is too big but this
touches almost every industry and it
raises the question of what sort of
economy do we want the UK to be
the halls of power will have to take
into consideration the student Halls of
Lambeth and a lot else besides Tom
Cheshire Sky News South London